290 seats over 7,000 candidates
campaigning has officially started but
the attention has not been on the
candidates standing but those
disqualified from taking part by Iran's
Guardian Council the constitutional body
that oversees the parliamentary
elections and claims that the
disqualifications have been politically
motivated I deny this the Guardian
Council has the duty to verify the
qualification of candidates and the
council has never had a political view
over them those who have not been
approved can come to us to see the issue
in their cases many of those
disqualified our politicians linked to
the Iranian reformist movement one of
those who's standing again is reformist
candidate Farida Mousavi
it was an unfortunate event some of her
colleagues and friends from the past
four years who have been cooperating
with us were not given the chance to run
in elections some of them have been
treated unfairly
but typed on the streets it's hard to
tell there's an election taking place
although campaigning has officially
started for now Iran's capital isn't
showing signs that it's an election new
jet here in one of the city's central
squares there's no banners no posters
and no candidates canvassing the lack of
interest has been blamed on the current
economic situation
last November saw widespread protests
against the fuel price increase other
areas of the economy are reeling under
punitive US sanctions politicians are
trying to relate to people's economic
woes I'm aware of the difficult
situation and economic hardship that
today parts of our society are
struggling with the path to change this
condition is neither silence nor staying
away from voting we should come together
to the center of events to be able to
trigger change has been called by some
to boycott the elections while leaders
have urged people to come out to vote a
good turnout will give legitimacy to the
Iranian political establishment
something Iran wants to use to silence
its western and domestic critics Assad
big al Jazeera that Iran